Over the past two weeks,
I've been spotlighting
various black voices
to learn as much as I can
during these insane times.
My guest tonight is a
very talented comedian
and actor who has carved
his own unique path
through the entertainment industry.
He's also one of the most
loving fathers I know.
His new show Nice One
will be premiering later
this summer on Quibi, please welcome my
really good friend Ron Funches.
Ron, good to see you.
Hey Coco, how you doing?
How dare you call me Coco.
How dare, you know, disrespect me?
(laughing)
You know, we have so much to talk about.
Obviously, the last two weeks
has been so many things,
it's been traumatic and
upsetting and at times violent
and there's, I mean, I think
what good is coming out
of it is that there's
been a lot of discussion
and we've been trying to
do that here on the show.
One of the things I wanted to talk
to you about is that when,
when you saw what happened
to George Floyd, I'm sure
this brought up a lot
of feelings about your
own son, your son who has,
you've worried about,
you've told me in the past
that you about your son and
about your son's autism,
and that this has been a specific concern
of yours for his safety out in the world.
Is that true?
Yeah, absolutely.
It's been a concern of
mine for many years.
It's one of my most motivating things
in my life just that because
of him being mixed race,
meaning half black and half
white and having autism
and not being, you know,
he's just doesn't follow
directions as easily.
He doesn't respond to
directions as quickly
as some people would like
and I was always concerned
that that if he was in an altercation
with a police officer
that that could mean the end of his life.
So it was something that
was deeply concerned
to the point where, you know,
I didn't necessarily like him
out of my sight that much,
I didn't and a lot of
my motivation was trying
to insulate that with money.
Being like, Okay, if we can surround him
in a good neighborhood,
if we can surround him
with a nanny that's there,
even though he's 17 years old,
we have a full time nanny
just to make sure that someone
is with him and it's not
because he's not independent,
he's very independent it's a lot to do
with my fear about what could happen
with misunderstandings with others,
especially people like the
police or people with power.
Yeah, and you know I was talking yesterday
to the mayor of Saint Paul,
Minnesota and we were
talking about this concept
that maybe in some situations you don't,
it shouldn't be automatic
that the police are called,
that it might be some
sort of health workers
that are called for some situations
so that response is a little more nuanced
and that's something you've
thought about with your son,
which is, you know, you
don't necessarily want
the police showing up if
you're having an issue
with your son.
No, and that that really says a lot right
there that if you are in a bad situation,
if you're, if things are
feeling out of control,
like you don't want the
police because the fear
is that they will escalate the situation.
Their job is usually to
just try to get the peace
and order as quick as possible
and if that means removing a situation,
if that means they have to shoot someone,
it seems like that is a quicker option
to them then trying to figure
out what the problem is,
trying to be empathetic
to what the problem is.
It's something I dealt with
when my son was was younger,
when he was five, six, seven years old
and he would be overwhelmed
by different stimulus,
he would have these big tantrums
and it would involve
people calling the police
to my house and I was lucky
that it never escalated
but it did end up with like, you know,
no one ever came over and say, hey,
what can we do to help?
What was the issue?
What's was going on?
Instead, they would come
over, they would tell us
to shut it down and shut him up
and then they would call Child Services
and then we'd have to deal with that.
It was always like, you're a bad parent
or you don't know what
you're doing as opposed to,
you need help and I think that's something
where health services and people trained
in that can be much more
helpful especially dealing
with anyone with any type of
mental diversity or disability,
you don't want someone who's not familiar
with that coming into the situation.
I believe that your son Malcolm
is named after Malcolm X, is that right?
Yes, that is correct.
It's interesting because when
I Look at the actual footage
of Malcolm X, he's the most one
of the most charismatic person
that people I've ever seen
captured in documentary footage.
He's got that same thing that Muhammad Ali
had where he can just, he's
such a powerful presence and ...
He can rapture you.
Yeah, exactly when did you, I mean,
obviously if you named your son Malcolm
must have been an important figure to you,
is this your whole life?
It started probably around when I was 11,
12 years old while I
was still getting ready
to leave Chicago.
One of the best things that my school
ever did for me was take me
to go see the autobiography
of Malcolm X when it was
starring Denzel Washington
and that kind of started
my infatuation with him
and then I read his autobiography
and then I started to read more speeches
that he had done and then it became clear
to me that like this was a guy
who had become marginalized
by history as just like
just black separatists
that all his stuff was
about, like, you know,
separating black people from
white people and that was then,
that was not the truth.
It was all about black love and pride
and a lot of it was just about power
and oppression and
unionizing and healthcare.
He talks about a lot of
things about unionizing
and healthcare that are
still needed to this day,
that we don't deal with
and I think it's so funny
that people go back and
they glorify rightfully
so Martin Luther King, but they
also whitewash his history.
He was not as, he was more
militant than people think
and Malcolm X was less
militant than people think.
They both just talked about,
they were like two sides
of a coin that were headed
to the same direction
and I think, you know,
now they they invoke
Martin Luther King's name
to kind of pacify us, to
kind of say your supposed
to just march and speech and you know
that Martin Luther did
and if you don't do that,
you're disrespecting Martin
Luther King and it's just like,
I don't wanna hear that from when he
was on the FBI most wanted list,
when he was murdered by our government,
when those are things that
now they celebrate him
when they did this damnedest
to discredit him just,
to say that he was a
womanizer and to kill him,
and then now, you know,
they're trying to tell another story.
Right, one of the things that, you know,
I don't think I was unaware
of this but what I'm hearing
again and again from friends
of mine is, who are black is that they've,
they say that they
experienced racism sometimes,
but it's almost at a frequency
that their white friends don't pick up
on it but black people pick up on it.
And that's something that
you're quite familiar with,
you'll be in a situation
where something might happen
and you'll feel Wait a
minute, that didn't feel right
to me but your white friends
who you think are pretty woke,
don't hear it.
Is that true?
Yeah, it is true, it's
seems to be just operation.
How do I put it?
Do you think that you have to prove
it to them, but if they
don't see it firsthand,
if it's not someone
calling you the N word,
throwing you to the ground,
I think that's what made
the George Floyd situation
so unavoidable that you
could look at it directly
and you see the smugness, you see the lack
of empathy you see the
fact that he has his knee
on the back of a person's neck,
which is not needed for any
situation, so you can avoid it.
But a lot of the things you can avoid,
a lot of the things that people
would come to me and like,
maybe you misheard or
maybe you just picked up
the wrong tone or maybe you had a bad day
and I've been lucky that
like my best friend,
my friend Gabe who features for me,
he's been more open to it
and it's probably because he
had a black stepdad for a
while, he had black members
in his family and I remember
recently we were traveling,
and we just stopped in
this airport for coffee
and then the guy was
giving out coffee to people
and my friend was before me
and he talks to my friend,
he's like hey good morning,
how's everything going?
How's your day?
Where are you headed to?
And he gets to me and he
doesn't say a word to me.
He just, I just order
he gives me my coffee
and he shuts completely down
and then the next person
that comes by is the
white lady and he's back
to the same and so then
I was like, Oh Okay,
I get it and then I was
fortunate at that time
that my friend was there
to look over and go,
that guy's a he's a freak racist
and sometimes that's what you need,
it's not necessarily
that that ruined my day
or I cared that much about that coffee.
I have learn to this situation of like,
I'm just passing through,
if that's how he's living
he's having a horrible day
and he's racist then
that's where he belongs,
just serving coffee out in the middle
of nowhere I'm passing through.
But what sometimes that we
need is just validation,
just knowing that, hey,
even if you didn't see it,
even if you don't wanna
believe it, it happens
and you gotta take people's word for it.
I think that's the thing
that I've been seeing
the most is that, like, the
African American community
is the only group that has to prove
that they didn't deserve to die, you know,
that we have to explain
why, what did he do?
Why you get something?
Well, George Floyd had a
record, he did this 2007,
he did this 2009, it's like,
there's no other race
there's no other group
that you'd have to explain
why you don't deserve
to be murdered.
Yeah, yeah.
You and I went on the tour a year ago,
a little over a year
ago, and we spent a lot
of time together and so was there anything
that happened while we
were on that tour together
that that made you feel at all strange
or feel marginalized while
we were on the road together
or on different tours?
I have done some different
tours definitely,
I wouldn't say there was
any event that happened
on our tour.
I would say the only
thing that I was aware
of is that I had this mindset
that if I strayed too far
from the group that some
people might be like,
what are you doing?
Why are you like, why are
you trying to get into this?
Like, are you like trying to rob
them or are you trying like,
you don't belong here basically.
Wait, why did you feel this is?
It's a feeling that I carried,
that I should not get
too far from the group,
that I should had to show
them that I was with you.
Right.
It is because if I felt
that if I was alone,
they'd go why are you in this fancy hotel?
Why are you here?
What are you doing here?
And that happens to me more on like,
because I love to travel,
I love to vacation
and that's happened to me
several times on vacation
or several times in my
stores where I would,
I used to do this thing that
if they treat me poorly,
I'd buy more stuff so that I proved
to them you were wrong
and now I was like no,
I'm just not gonna make
sure you just don't get
that commission, you know.
(laughing)
So what you're saying is in order to prove
that you were there with good intent,
you would like buy a canoe even
if you didn't want a canoe?
(laughing)
Yes.
I think its the canoe.
(laughing)
That's the strangest response
to feeling marginalized.
(laughing)
It's not you see it a lot of time,
it's called peacocking.
Is it something that is happens
in the black community
where you see a lot of like,
fancy cars, fancy clothes, because this
is a showcase of like, hey,
you shouldn't treat me poorly,
instead of it being
like I'm a human so you
shouldn't treat me poorly.
You know, that's one of the
biggest lessons I learned
as a young black man is that I thought,
for some strange dumb
reason I thought like,
if I get a little bit of money
then they'll stop treating me
like this and then I learned
that that wasn't the case.
(laughing)
So you'll be on it, I mean,
you've done very well,
you'll be on a vacation, you'll
be staying in a nice place
and you'll sometimes sense
that people are wondering,
how is he here?
What's he doing here?
Is he a guest of this hotel?
I've had it happen,
I've had a bellhop tried
to stop me from entering
my own hotel room.
Because I went outside for a jog
and I come back in my
shorts, and I'm sweaty
and he's just like, hey,
what are you doing here?
What are you doing here?
And then I have headphones
on so I'm not even paying attention,
so I just go walking by
and he starts following me
and yelling at me like, Who are you?
What are you doing here?
So I just turn around and
I show him my key card
and then I flip them off.
(laughing)
That was into that.
Right, right.
I'm glad I'm glad you
had the correct response,
I mean you were able to do that.
There's this belief some
people have that racism is,
that it's a generational aspect to racism
that it's worse with older
generations but as we move on
and people get younger and
newer generations come along,
it's getting better.
That is not always been
your experience, right?
No, not always, I mean I do believe
that there is always progress
and it's I think the more that
we become culturally mixed
the more that these kids
have grown up off of hip hop
and and seeing black people
in positions of power
and representation, the better it gets.
But no, I know plenty you turn
on a game of Call of Duty,
you turn on any video game
and it's not your grandpa
calling me the N word you know,
it's a 12 year old kid,
it's a 13 year old kid
and you see it at these
Trump camp rallies,
they're not 80 year old people.
Right, right.
They're 20 year old white
men who have found a way
to make themselves feel disenfranchised,
and make themselves feel like the victim
and use that national that white pride
and that racism to fuel themselves.
So to me, that's one of
the biggest disservice we
do as a community is going,
well we just need to wait 10,
20 years for our grandparents to die.
Right, right.
And it's like, well, we've
been waiting 100 years
for that and so those
grandparents, teach the kids
and teach the grandkids and you
got to look within yourself,
it's not just about your parents.
You have a very unique
comedic voice and style
and it's something I've always
really admired about you
and yet at the same time,
I'm imagining it's been a struggle
for you to not get typecast
because of the color of your skin.
Yeah, absolutely, absolutely.
I knew that from very first
when I went to Montreal
when I was a new face
gentleman, Brandon Johnson,
who was a great African American comedian,
and an actor came up
to me and he was like,
I saw your set, he's like,
you're weird and you're black,
your role is gonna be different
and longer and strange
but keep being you, don't
ever change for these people
and I've always kept that
and it's been a source
of anger and frustration
for me that my comedy
is built off of love,
is built off of empathy,
is built out of optimism, it's built off
of making the best of a bad situation
and a lot of times the
roles that are offered
to me are that of a gang member,
or that of a guy fresh out of jail,
or that of a guy where I have to change
the way I speak, to speak more urban to,
to fit into a role that
they want me to fit
into and I just don't
feel that that's fair,
especially in this time period, you know,
we still representation i think
is one of the biggest things,
laws are gonna be very important
just not police brutality
obviously is the step,
is a great step but
representation and being willing
to show different facets
of the black community
is something that we still
struggle with every day,
every pilot season, I get
just more and more sitcoms
where either it's a struggle role
of a black guy lifting
themselves out of poverty,
or it's clearly a white
roll that they're trying
to shoehorn some diversity
into and there's just
multiple black stories
and multiple types of way that people
can be viewed in the community
and that's something I try
to write towards, and try to
create because I don't like
the roles that I'm offered, basically.
I know that you've been
on my show many times,
always been hilarious.
You did stand up on my
show once and I know
there was a joke you wanted to to do
or that you were planning to do,
and the joke involved
you using the N word,
and I don't think I was aware
of this at the time but one
of our producers said, well, you can't say
that word on Turner Broadcasting.
So we were in the position of being white
and telling you you can't use the N word,
which was just sort of a weird situation.
Was that something that
bothered you when that happened?
Of course it bothered me a little bit
but it wasn't something
that I didn't expect,
you know, I was like let me attempt to do
this joke because I love it and again,
I think it shows my style
of someone who looks
at for the positive in
every negative situation.
But I didn't expect you guys
to let me say N word on TV,
so I wasn't mad about it but
I you know, when you look
at it you go like this
is just a weirder form
of oppression where there's
a guilt about this word that,
you know, that we've taken
as the black community
to as a source of empowerment for us
and then they go like okay,
well now that you guys don't hate
it as much you can't say it.
(laughing)
Can I hear the joke or wait?
Can we hear the joke now?
Yeah, I can tell you I mean,
I don't remember is 100%
because it was years ago,
but I remember the event.
It was just about the time
I was gonna go get my son,
Papa Murphy's Take 'N' Bake pizza,
where he was walking across my apartment
across this two lane, big street
that we had and as I was
growing across the street,
I hear this guy yell, hey,
use the crosswalk N word
and it pissed me off
because I was like man,
like there's so much racism in the world,
everybody's full of hatred I'm just trying
to get my son a pizza.
But then I thought, Oh
yeah, he's in a car,
maybe I just didn't hear the
rest of the conversation.
He and what he was trying to say was,
use the crosswalk nigga I'm
worried about your own safety.
You know like okay.
(laughing)
That's a really good joke.
You're always able to see the
silver lining I guess, huh?
Yes, I try.
(laughing)
He's worried about my safety.
You know, we've hung out
a lot, we spend a lot
of time together, we've been
in vans, we've been on planes,
we've been backstage.
I'm trying to figure out as best I
can, how I can, you know, how I can learn
and how I can grow and evolve
and so if you have advice
for me, I'll take it.
Sure, I was thinking about this last night
cause I think a lot of people, alright,
are in your position a lot of white people
are at a position where they're,
this is new to them.
(laughing)
Which is hilarious to us
but I appreciate you trying
to look in, but I think
a lot of it is like,
look don't be so egotistical
it's not about you,
it's about us, it's about the things
that we're going through and the fact
that you can be listening
and open to that is great.
But I thought I did a
little bit more thinking
and I thought the best
thing I could tell you
is just be an active ally, be if you see,
you're in a privileged position
that sometimes white people
will reveal their racism
to you because you're white
and they don't think that
you might have an issue
with it or they might
feel more comfortable
with revealing their true
selves to you as opposed
to me you know, and I think
if you are in that position
and you see that to never let that go.
To never always check people
if they are in that position
and you see them acting out
alone, you know, or
treating someone poorly
to never let them know that that is okay.
That is the thing that is the best thing
that you can do.
Okay, okay, I have had the
experience over the years
of African Americans,Black people
whenever I see them in their familiar
with my show they always
say the same thing,
you're crazy.
(laughing)
Yeah, Black people love you
for as white and lily white
is you are you are loved
in the Black community.
I think it's because you
are so awkwardly tall
and look like an outcast yourself.
(laughing)
I always say the same thing,
they start laughing and they
say you're crazy, you're crazy.
Yes.
That always and actually, it's a nice way
to start the conversation.
You know which works out?
Well, I really appreciate
you coming on the show
and having this conversation with me
and I want to apologize
again, when we were on tour,
singing songs towards you
with my acoustic guitar
when I think I knew it drove you crazy.
(laughing)
Literally love to be like
(laughs)
it's me at my absolute
whitest which is so white
and I would see you and I'd
be like, I'm gonna do it again
and you were very vocal about it.
(laughs)
And you considered it a
unique form of torture.
(laughing)
Well, yeah about this what I
love about our relationship
is that I can say, I can tell you that,
I can say it.
That's what?
You didn't just tell me that,
you then went out in
front of, I don't know,
3000 people in a giant venue
and you told them the most
horrible thing just happened
to me when I was backstage
playing this guitar.
(laughing)
You made fun of me brutally
in front of all these people
and I loved it, it was
absolutely hilarious
and I had to comment.
It needed to be, you know,
I figured if it happened
to me that much it must happen
to your staff all the time.
So I needed to stand up for them.
(laughing)
You did the right thing,
you did the right thing.
Well, thank you so much
for doing this, I love you,
I can't wait till we get
to hang out in person
and thank you so much
for doing this today.
You're a good man, thank you.
I love you too, I
appreciate you doing this.
This is a great thing that you're doing
and I think I like that
you're looking into yourself,
but you've always,
you've done a great job,
you've hired a lot of
diversity and the fact
that you had Deon Cole on your
show when I was a young man,
it meant a lot to me as
a young Black comedian,
because it was one of the
few guys where I was like,
this is not he's not doing a stereotype,
he's not doing a stick.
He's a weird Black dude doing himself
and you gave him a platform to show
that and then in turn that empowered me.
Yeah, he's such a funny guy
and you're such a funny guy
and well, I'll see you soon,
I promise you'll never hear me sing again.
(laughs)
Please.
(laughing)
See, if all I do is, if I can grow
that much I can grow more.
All right, thank you very much Ron
and I'll talk to you soon.